item two of the agenda
Japan
[Music]
thank you very much Madam president
members of the security Council
more than five weeks
have passed since eruption of fighting
between the Sudanese armed forces and
the rapid support forces in Sudan on 15
April
despite repeated earlier Declarations of
ceasefire by both sides
there has been no day
without fighting and neither side has
been able to claim
a military victory
the agreement on a short-term ceasefire
and humanitarian Arrangements which was
signed two days ago in Jeddah
is an important step forward
it offers hope for the civilians and it
shows
that the violence can be ended
if both sides comply I will return to
this at the end of my short presentation
Sudan's civilian population
has already paid a heavy price for this
senseless violence
according to estimates of C doctors
Union
more than 860 civilians have been killed
including more than 190 children
with another 3500 civilians injured
we are missing over a million have been
displaced more than 840 000 have sought
shelter in safer parts of the country
while another 250 000 or so have crossed
Sudanese borders
do not capture
the harrowing stories of thousands of
men and women who abandoned their homes
in search for safety across the borders
many have waited for days and weeks at
border crossings to secure a passage
and neither of these figures illustrates
the suffering of many others who could
not leave and stay in their homes with
depleted supplies and no access to
humanitarian assistance
I'm grateful to those countries who are
receiving refugees and returnees fleeing
Sudan
it's vital
that borders remain open
to those who seek safety
procedures at border crossings should be
expedited
the United Nations continues to Avail
our support to alleviate the burden on
neighboring states and ensure that
refugees that Refugee needs are met with
dignity
Madam president
in cartoon and therefore and elsewhere
the warring parties have fought their
war with little regard for the laws and
Norms of War homes shops places of
worship water and electricity
installations have been destroyed or
damaged
the health sector is collapsing
with more than two-thirds of hospitals
closed
many healthcare workers killed and
medical supplies running low
frequently reported use of Health
Facilities as military positions is
unacceptable
I'm appalled
by the reports of sexual violence
against women and girls including
allegations of rape and cartoon and
therefore
the United Nations is following up to
verify these cases
the warring parties must prevent any
reoccurrence of such violence
children
are facing serious protection concerns
and continue to be vulnerable to
recruitment
sexual violence and abduction
reports of rampant blue Tink of
intimidation harassment and enforced
disappearance are deeply concerning
U.N premises and Residences including
the uni terms compound as well as large
amounts of food and humanitarian
supplies have also been looted
criminality is compounded by the release
of thousands of prisoners and the
increasing spread of small arms
and I'm also concerned
about reported death threats against
political activities activists and
leaders
about the arrest of the arrests of
Sudanese volunteers and the intimidation
of journalists
excellencies
in parts of the country
fighting between the two armies or the
two armed formations
has sharpened intercommunal tensions or
triggered conflict between communities
in ajinena and Western 4
clashes between the Sudanese armed
forces and the rapid support forces a
spiraled into ethnic violence on 24
April
tribal militias joins a fight
and civilians took up arms to defend
themselves homes markets hospitals were
ransacked and burned U.N premises
pollutant
in mid-may renewed violence led to more
death and destruction
altogether more than 250 persons were
reportedly killed
tens of thousands were displaced to
neighboring Chad
the security situation is impeding the
delivery of humanitarian Aid I continue
I continue to engage national and local
leaders to de-escalate the situation
warning signs of tribal mobilization are
also reported in other parts of the
country particularly in South Korean as
well as the Blue Nile region
the fighting throughout the country has
resulted in serious human rights abuses
and violations of international
humanitarian law and undermines the
protection of civilians
these violations must be investigated
and the perpetrators
must be brought to Justice
the United Nations family continues to
monitor and advocate for an end
to all these violations
members of the council
some commentators
have placed the blame for this conflict
on the International Community
for not having seen warning signs
others blame the political process or
the framework agreement which intended
to lead to a civil Inlet government
or blames the International Community
for giving an outsized role in the
process
to the main with guns
but let us be clear
the responsibility for the fighting
rests with those who are waging it daily
the leadership of the two sides who have
chosen to settle their unresolved
conflict on the battlefield
rather than at the table
it's their decision
that is ravaging Sudan and they
can end it
what has been happening on and since
April 15 is precisely
was the United Nations and our partners
in the International Community tried to
prevent
before and after 25 October
military takeover of 2021
we engage diligently with the two
military and with civilian leaders to
persuade them to talk
and to return to a meaningful transition
to civilian rule
through political process
as the tensions grew amidst reports of a
buildup of forces
I raised the alarm in my briefing to
this Council here in March and I urge
the parties to de-escalate
weeks prior to the outbreak of fighting
I alongside with my partners in the
trilateral mechanism as a quad
intensified our engagement with the
military leaders to de-escalate the
situation
we coordinated these efforts with
Sudanese civilians and also tried to
mediate between the generals who also
tried I'm sorry to mediate between the
generals recognizing the gravity
of the situation
and we asked Regional actors
to lose to use their leverage with the
two parties
our efforts continued
until the night before April 15
when we thought progress had been made
only to wake up the next morning to the
reality that the parties had chosen War
Madam president
unfortunately the hostilities compelled
us
to temporarily relocate to temporarily
relocate many of our staff to Port Sudan
and outside Sudan
this does not mean let me be very clear
here this does not mean that we have
abandoned the Sudanese people or the
Sudan
we continue to work with our Sudanese
partners and we remain firmly committed
to for immediate priorities first
achieving a stable ceasefire with a
monitoring mechanism second
preventing the escalation or
ethnicization of the conflict
third
protection of civilians and provision of
humanitarian relief
and fourth preparing
for when the time is right ripe a fresh
political process with a participation
of a broad array of civil and political
actors including women
through our Hub in Port Sudan
uni terms has supported the efforts of
our country team and humanitarian
Partners to restore the flow of
humanitarian supplies into and within
the country
the United Nations family is doing our
utmost
to expand our response throughout the
country
particularly in areas of acute need
but it's also essential that the east of
the country there is Red Sea state where
Port Sudanese and casilla and gedarev
it's east of the country are not only
used as an entry point for humanitarian
Aid but receive a fair share of it not
least with regards to the increasing
movement of displaced people to this
region
additional funding is urgently needed
the revised humanitarian response plan
was launched on 17 May
requesting 2.6 billion dollars to reach
18 million people in need up from 15
million before the fighting began
Madam president excellencies
thanks to Saudi and U.S mediation
representatives of the Sudanese armed
forces and the rapid support forces
signed a declaration of commitments in
Jeddah on 11th May
and an agreement on a short-term
ceasefire and humanitarian Arrangements
on 20 May
it is supposed
to agreement on short-term ceasefire it
is supposed to enter into Force tonight
it shall remain in effect for seven days
it is renewable
and it should allow civilians to move
and humanitarian access to get to the
people
this is a welcome
development
those are fighting and troop movements
have continued even today
despite the commitment of both sides not
to pursue military Advantage before the
ceasefire takes effect
we understand
that a basic monetary mechanism will be
set up between the two parties and the
mediators
uni term stands ready to support
monitoring and monitoring mechanism for
the longer term or for a permanent
ceasefire
we can build on the staff and the
structures that have been established in
the permanent ceasefire committee for
therefore which uni terms has been
sharing since mid-2021.
I continue to urge the parties to honor
this agreement which they signed two
days ago
they must they must stop the fighting
they must allow access for humanitarian
relief
protect humanitarian workers and assets
and allow safe passage for civilians to
leave areas of hostilities
we'll also continue to engage the
leadership of the Sudanese armed forces
and the rapid support forces
to ensure the protection of civilians
and civilian infrastructure
while pushing for an end to this war
we are coordinating closely with
Sudanese Partners working for peace
let me also commence the leaders of the
Armed movements for their efforts to
restore peace I mean the art movement
signatories to the Juba peace agreement
for their efforts to restore peace and
for their neutrality in this conflict
Sudanese Civil Society is playing a
strong role in advocating for peace
while continuing to support civilians in
need
their efforts must be supported
both parties both parties
have been calling on me
to condemn the respective other side's
actions
I call on both to end the fighting
and to return to dialogue in the
interest of Sudan and its people
lives and infrastructure have been
destroyed
the growing ethnicization of the
conflict risks to expand and prolong it
with implications for the region
the agreed short-term ceasefire could
and should also pave the way for talks
for a durable cessation of hostilities
talks advance
a diverse array of civil and political
stakeholders must play their role
ultimately
only a credible civilian-led transition
can chart lasting peace in Sudan
I know it's an appointment of maligagar
signatory of sujuba peace agreement and
chair of the recently formed peace block
as vice president of the transitional
sovereignty Council
agar stated
that his overall priority is to reach a
permanent ceasefire
to end the war and to silence the guns
this certainly deserves our endure
full support
Regional and international efforts to
end the fighting in Sudan are laudable
as these efforts multiply
we must ensure coordination to forge a
common approach
that will enhance our Collective
leverage and the effectiveness
effectiveness of our efforts
any coordinated plan must involve
Sudan's neighbors and the region and I'm
very glad my colleagues commissioner
bankole an executive secretary Dr
werkner would speak and be able to go
into more details
regarding the efforts of the trilateral
partners the UN African Union and egot
United Nations will continue to work
closely with our partners in this
trilateral mechanism the Au and Egert in
support of these efforts and
coordination with others thank you very
much
foreign
[Music]
on behalf of the African Union at the
outset
let me assure you and through you
this esteemed organ
of the full cooperation
of the African Union for the success of
your deliberations and engagements
on African issues particularly
Sudan
the worrisome situation
in the Sudan
which is on your agenda today is
engaging the attention of the African
Union at the highest level
you are aware
how greatly
we were mobilized from the very first
day
of the overthrow of the former president
[Music]
to support the efforts to resolve the
post-revolution challenges in the Sudan
the Au with the support of Partners work
to put in place a mediation Arrangement
that was suspected to lead to an
inclusive smooth
blood-based political transition
the Au deployed active and effective
radiation
with the support of au member states and
development Partners in 2019
in general
this was the satisfaction the Sudanese
people and partners when an
Institutional transitional mechanism or
a peaceful
unbalanced transition
was established
unfortunately
the acute internal contradictions
wasn't by fragmentation and polarization
among the political
and Military actors in Sudan
coupled with the multiplicity of
external interference undermined the
transition
and of course this led to his terminate
resulting in the irresponsible and
senseless coup
of 25th of October 2021
here you condemn the coup
and eventually dictated by its normative
principles and shared values suspended
Sudan while continuing to work with
partners for a rapid restoration of
constitutional order and the conceptual
transition
in doing so we established the
trilateral mechanism
and collaboratively worked with the
United Nations
he got
along with the AU
a political framework agreement as you
know was signed in December 2022
and what was underway to ensure its
extension to all political actors or
more inclusivity
Madam president
however the outbreak of hostilities on
the 15th of April 20 2023 between the
Sudanese armed forces and Rapid support
forces tragically dashed our hopes
this
will have led to the resumption of
political transition process and
civilian-led Democratic law
since then
here you have been working relentlessly
to ensure an end to this current
conflict
on the 16th of April exactly one day
after the outbreak of hostilities
the African Union peace and Security
Council conveyed to consider the crisis
in Sudan
condemned the fighting call for an
immediate and unconditional ceasefire
and requested the chairperson of the
commission to use his good offices to
ensure that he guns are silenced
on April 20 2023 the Au commission
chairperson brought together key actors
in The International Community to
coordinate and intensify their efforts
for an immediate ceasefire
as well as humanitarian assistance and
the resumption of the political process
consequently on 2nd May
you convened the mechanism this expanded
mechanism
and consultations are underway for his
full operationalization
our conviction is that only
a well-coordinated collective action
would give chance
to the success of international action
for peace and stability in Sudan
separate competing or rival actions will
further complicate and undermine
research or a peaceful resolution of the
crisis
it is in this context that the African
Union has developed a comprehensive
de-escalation plan
which identifies six pillars that need
to be addressed for a sustainable
resolution of the Sudanese conflict
permit me to highlight the six pillars
one the coordinated International action
to avoid a proliferation and duplication
of mediation initiatives
true immediate
unconditional permanence and
comprehensive ceasefire
three
urgent humanitarian action to relieve
the suffering of the Sudanese people
for protection of civilians State
infrastructure and to ensure
accountability for actions taken by the
warring parties
five
support to neighboring countries in the
region that have been impacted by this
crisis
a sixth resumption of fully
representative inclusive political
process towards the return of democratic
civilian-led government
Madam chair
we are expectant that African leaders
will further meet under the auspices of
the African Union peace and Security
Council later this week to endorse the
African Union the escalation plan
the situation in Sudan remains there as
as srsg borka as described the
destruction of public and private
institutions is systematic unfortunately
this is the case with health academic
economic Financial social and
humanitarian institutions the sick and
the wounded are dying without any care
this is totally unacceptable
gross human rights violations are
rampant arrest looting sexual assaults
are on the rise
the urgency
is to put an end to the fighting without
delay
it is exigent that Council should assume
responsibility in the face of this
intolerable and unnecessary conflict
the African Union closely monitored the
steps taken by Saudi Arabia and the
United States in Jeddah we also welcome
the commitment displayed by the two
Warren parties
for signing a short-term ceasefire and
humanitarian arrangement
however
we call for more concerted
actionable effort towards a lasting
cessation of hostilities
we ought them to go the full course for
peace
a comprehensive permanent silencing of
the guns now is the only remedy for the
good people of Sudan
the resumption of the political
transition premised on inclusive
political dialogue and National
reconciliation that brings together all
actors of the Sudanese Society
fully complemented by the International
Community will promote peace and
stability in the siddhan
Madam President we must now collectively
start planning for inclusive
negotiations on a political process
that will be
agreed to by the Sudanese people
it is important that we take on board
the relationship between the center and
the periphery between the state and its
citizens between Sudan
and its neighbors
so that the Sudanese can build the Sudan
that they want
the African Union is working to support
such an inclusive process
which will allow for the full
representation of all voices of the
sectors of the Sudanese civil society
and political parties
Eau is also striving to ensure that
states bordering Sudan which are
endlessly receiving growing numbers of
traumatized Sudanese and refugees are
systemic at this difficult time
here you will be deploying special
envoys
as directed by the chairperson of the
commission is Excellence musafaki to all
the neighboring countries in due course
a strong commitment by Council to a
ceasefire the implementation of
humanitarian assistance and the
resumption of the political process
is imperative
so that a United coherent International
Coalition
imperative to promote peace in Sudan we
must arrest Sudan's slide into complete
collapse or chaos
this will have unbearable consequences
for the region of the African continent
and the World At Large I thank you very
much excellencies
foreign
Excellency members of the new and
Security Council
ladies and gentlemen
allow me to be to begin my statement by
thanking this August body
or convening yet another meeting
or the situation of Sudan and inviting
IGA to brief you and share our views and
perspectives
the Security Council is continued
engagement and follow up on development
in Sudan is much appreciated and needed
excellencies
it got well welcomes the signing of the
agreement
on short term ceasefire and humanitarian
arrangement in Sudan
between representatives of
Sudan Arabic forces and Rapid support
force on 20th of May
2023 in Jeddah Saudi Arabia
brokered by the Kingdom of Saudi Arabia
and the United States of America
this latest development is a command
level progress and makes us to
cautiously optimistic that a permanent
cessation facility is with a rich
as per the agreement
the ceasefire will remain in
other days effective from today
and is subject to extension based on the
agreement of the parties
and also we are very happy the agreement
is aimed at among others
facilitating the delivery and
distribution of humanitarian assistance
restoration of essential services
and withdrawn of forces from the
hospitals and essential Public Services
which is much needed for the people of
Republic of Sudan
the fact that previous ceasefire
agreements were violated repeatedly
the last five weeks may win our hope and
trust
in the respect for current FIFA
agreement by the warring parties
however
it is not worthy that unlike previous
agreements
we are happy that the parties have
signed this agreement and also it will
be monitored
by a U.S Saudi supported ceasefire
monitoring mechanism
irrespective of challenges that may be
faced in the implementation
it is progress Wars capitalizing and
building upon
excellencies
the five weeks of fighting has had a
heavy toll on the people of the Republic
of Sudan
reporters indicated us
srg Walker has indicated
this is the beginning of
a very big challenge that the people of
Sudan is facing as innocent otherwise
we collectively stop this violence and
conflict
the longer the fighting takes
the higher the toll would be
it will also further complicate and
compound the crisis as a new internal
and external actors may be involved in
the conflict
most importantly shortage of food
medical facilities and service will
exacerbate the humanitarian cries
besides the people of Sudan of
excellencies neighboring countries are
also feeling the burden of the war and
they are hosting thousands of refugees
and these are countries who are either
emerging out of the conflict
or are facing serious economic and
humanitarian crisis by themselves
for instance the Republic of South
Sultan which has closed economic and
social ties with the students with the
Republic of Sudan has been impacted by
the conflict at the price of Woods has
spiked
and the purchasing power of the South
Sudanese pound has weakened since the
conflict broken out
in the Republic of Sudan
it is due to the close historical
social and economic size that the eager
member states have the Sudanese
as well as the direct impact that the
war is having on these countries
as a result of the Europe geographical
proximity that igad has been actively
working together with other partners
organizations and stats to secure
ceasefire
in this regard the high level eager
delegation led by his Excellency
salvation Madrid has been engaging the
warring parties on a daily basis and
Consulting and coordinating with
regional and international actors
on 17th and 18th of May
I was in Dubai South Sudan to encourage
his Excellency president Salvage on his
commitment to lead igad's efforts to
resolve the cries in Sudan and also
exchange views on the next step to be
taken to silence the guns in the
Republic of Sudan
I called on the international
community's support and complement these
efforts in coordinated manner
excellencies
despite our limited capacities and
resources igad and its members since are
doing whatever is possible within our
reach to support the people of Sudan
neighboring countries have also sent
humanitarian assistance
countries like Ethiopia South Sudan
Djibouti have also played
a key role in the evacuation of staff
and citizens of diplomatic missions
an international organizations based in
Sudan
it is high-tech your excellencies that
the International Community work closely
and support
this front flying countries to help them
provide adequate And Timely support to
the people of Sudan the refugees as well
as resending much needed humanitarian
support to so that
while I appreciate and command the
Kingdom of Saudi Arabia and the United
States of America
for the Relentless effort in
facilitating the Gita talks
I encourage them to involve and engage
the trilateral mechanism as the entity
trusted by Regional continental and
International Community to facilitate a
political process in the Republic of
Sudan
the only way we can stop the fighting in
Sudan Your Excellence is sooner rather
than later if
uh efforts are better coordinated
and streamline and our Collective
actions are Swifter
we all we all have one purpose and gone
into that
to silence the guns and resume the
inclusive Sudan is Led students owned
political process that will pave the way
toward the formation of civilian-led
traditional government
let us put our heads and hands together
to support
the Sudanese people pressed for durable
peace and democracy
at the experience from the region shows
chances of the Sexes are higher when
efforts are coordinated and neighboring
states are actively involved and engaged
in finding solution
I would like to end my remarks by
iterating eagerness unwavering
commitment to continue working and
coordinating closely with the United
Nations and other continental and
international actors as well as the
kingdom Saudi Arabia and the United
States of America towards achieving
permanent ceasefire and resumption of
the inclusive political process in Sudan
I thank you very much
[Music]
take the floor
thank you president
and thank you special representative
purchase
commissioner bankole and executive
secretary work near Gaba Yahoo for their
briefings
let me start by underlining our support
for SRS jupitas and all un staff who
continue to work in Sudan under
extremely challenging circumstances
president the conflict in Sudan is a
tragedy
and has had a devastating impact on the
Sudanese people
the United Kingdom urges the Sudanese
armed forces and the rapid support
forces to immediately stop fighting
protect civilians
and go out safe and immediate
humanitarian access
coordinating action by International and
Regional Partners is crucial to help end
this conflict
so we welcome all diplomatic efforts
towards this goal
including the May 11 Jetta declaration
and the ceasefire agreement agreed on
May the 20th
but these commitments will will be
worthless if they are not put into
action
or if they are used to secure military
advantage
we call on the parties to abide fully by
their commitments in letter and spirit
we also welcome the efforts of the AU
agads and the league of Arab states to
help bring an end to the violence
it is essential that there is a strong
coordination of efforts between Regional
and multilateral bodies
it is also imperative that the voices of
the Sudanese civilians are heard loud
and clear
they must be included at every stage of
the process especially in mediation
efforts to bring an end to the fighting
and ultimately to deliver a democratic
transition with a civilian government
president let me address the appalling
human rights and humanitarian situation
caused by this fighting
as we've heard
over 500 civilians have been killed
thousands injured
Millions more lack food and Medicine
in West Darfur visceral violence is is
igniting at a scale not experienced in
decades
over 150 000 people have been forced to
flee Sudan
the United Kingdom would like to extend
our thanks and pledge our support to the
neighboring countries who have welcomed
refugees
humanitarian need has risen sharply
having already been at record levels
prior to the conflict
so we call for an immediate end to the
continued attacks on civilian
infrastructure
including homes
Healthcare facilities schools and places
of worship
the Looting of humanitarian assets is
simply unacceptable
the perpetrators must be held
accountable
presidents in closing we offer our full
support to UNI terms as we enter
discussions on renewal of its mandate
and we stand in solidarity with the
Sudanese people in their demands for a
peaceful and Democratic future
thank you
for the representative of Mozambique
Madam the president
is
my honor to make this statement on
behalf of the earth
[Music]
and my own country Mozambique
we must see
him
this morning's briefings
is a very important contributions Sudan
Excellence
African Union security
Yahoo
secretary executive
Executives
on development
welcome the presence
Excellency the permanent representative
of Sudan at this meeting
Community terms
at the outset the A3
would like to commend you any terms
for the tremendous work
conducted in a very difficult
and challenging environment
that characterizes the current situation
in the Sudan
the invaluable work of uni terms
with the cooperation of the Sudanese
authorities
has facilitated
the evacuation of civilians diplomatic
personnel and humanitarian workers
from areas of intense fighting in the
Sudan
furthermore
uni terms has sought to continue with
humanitarian assistance to the Sudanese
people
despite all the challenges
the A3 deplores the dramatic
deterioration of the situation of the
Sudan
that undermines all the progress
achieved
particularly in the implementation of
the Juba peace agreement
it is evident
that the current crisis
puts the progress achieved thus far at
risk
therefore the A3
emphasizes the need for the parties
to silence the guns immediately and
return
to the parts of a negotiation
Gabon Ghana and Mozambique
command the leadership of the African
Union
and Regard in seeking solutions to
address the situation in the Sudan
we stress that the trilateral mechanism
is crucial to have a viable sustainable
and incredible political process
focusing on the research to dialogue
between the parties in conflict
to build
inclusive and long-standing peace in the
systolic country
da3
father command
the African Union
for the formulation
over this Coalition plan
which will concretely contribute to the
stabilization efforts
the Sudanese and forces
and the rapid support forces
are therefore encouraged
to fully embrace
the distillation plan
for the benefit of the Sudan
the Sudanese people and the region
we also welcome you need time strenuous
efforts toward the cessation of conflict
of hostilities
and the return of true political
negotiations
we take this opportunity to encourage
many times
to continue to assist the political
transition in the Sudan supported the
peace process
and the implementation of the Juba
agreement
Madame President
the security situation the Sudan is
deteriorating
and alarming due to the current crisis
it has created a conducive environment
for exacerbating the inter-cominal
clashes that already continue to pose
security challenges in some region of
the country
particularly in the full
Blue Nile South and West cordovan status
this situation
poses serious security threats to the
seven
neighboring countries
human rights violations
including attacks on civilian population
particularly women children and
vulnerable people
diplomatic Personnel U.N and
humanitarian workers are being reported
and we condemn
we register with grave concern
the targeting of diplomatic premises
including widespread looting
of the United Nations premises
particularly in cartoon and the full
in this regard the ae3 condemns in the
strongest terms
such criminal actors
they are a serious breach of the Vienna
convention on diplomatic relations
we reiterate that targeting civilian
population
is totally unacceptable
it constitutes a gross violation
of international humanitarian law
perpetrators of such actors should be
brought to Justice in due course
Ghana
Gabon and Mozambique are a deeply
concerned about the spill of effects of
the current crisis
in the neighboring countries
including
the increase of cross-border flows of
refugees
which may lead to increase of violence
in this context there is a need for a
stronger collaboration
between uni terms and other U.N missions
and entities operating in the region in
Northern to properly identify our
warning signs of escalation or violence
in the region
Madam president
the humanitarian situation was already
dire in the Sudan
with the eruption of this armed
confrontations
and the disruption of chains of supply
of several products
Associated to the already socio-economic
vulnerabilities
humanitarian situation
has become worse
the secretary General's report
indicated that more than 700 000 people
have been internally displaced
most of them
coming from cartoon
West Darfur
and South the full
with the current crisis more than 100
000 people are estimated to have left
the Sudan
in order to respond
to the humanitarian crisis the A3
reiterate the appeal for sustained
support for the 2023
humanitarian response plan for the Sudan
the plan targets 12.5 million people
through more than 200
projects
in case sectors
such as Education Health Child
Protection
gender-based violence and nutrition
we also encourage humanitarian
assistance
through other multilateral and the
bilateral mechanisms
paying particular attention to the
socioeconomic situation in the Sudan
the A3
welcomes all efforts and at achieving a
humanitarian truth and the establishment
of humanitarian corridors
we call for better coordination of all
the actors and the stress that need to
ensure that humanitarian assistance is
provided in the Sudan as well as in the
neighboring countries in compliance with
the guiding principles
governing the delivery of humanitarian
Aid
the A3
wish to reaffirm
the centrality of the role of the
African Union
egard and the trilateral mechanisms in
symbolizing the situation in the Sudan
we call for respect for Sudan's
sovereignty in dealing with their
challenges
Mozambique
pay attribute to the Sudanese people for
their courage and strength demonstrated
during this difficult times
while paying tribute to the Sudanese
people
we wish to state
that the Sudanese parties
must not lose sight of the central
objective
of resuming the transition process
towards an inclusive
democratic
civilian-led transition government that
is able to address the acute political
and economic recovery of the country
we urge the Sudanese people to refrain
from acts of violence and thread the
part of national Unity
reconciliation and the building of the
peace in the country I thank you madam
president
let me start by thanking the special
representative parts
commissioner
an executive secretary should be you for
providing essential briefings today
I welcome Ambassador Idris Muhammad and
Sudan's delegation to this meeting
I also recommend the tireless work of
hunitam's African Union any God personal
in a highly demanding situation
Madame President
Brazil is concerned by the humanitarian
challenges provoked by over a month of
continuous arms conflict
and in solidarity
with the people of Sudan
okay
excuse me
we commend the communities who have
assisted fleeing families in every
corner of Sudan and the Egypt chat the
Central African Republic South Sudan and
Ethiopia
we commend the vital work of the UN
personal and the humanitarian agencies
on the ground
I convey our appreciation for the
adjustments special representative parts
and unitums have made since 15 April to
implement the Nations mandate
Madam president
has argued by the Secretary General in
his latest report Sudan's rapid descent
into deadly conflict is a terrible
setback for the country
We Believe another terrible setback
would be the insistence on solving the
current conflict through military means
the United Nations the African Union
regards the league of Arab states and
virtually all partners of Sudan have
called for ceasefires and trucis
precisely because military means will
not solve the root causes of the ongoing
conflict
we also endorsed the Saudi American
initiative that led to the Declaration
of commitments to protect the civilians
of Sudan
we Echo the trilateral mechanism and
welcome the short-term ceasefire and
humanitarian Arrangements agreed upon in
on Saturday in Jeddah
Madam President we call on the saf and
the rsf to exercise maximum restraint
and uphold the truth
we encourage them to use negotiation
mediation dialogue and peaceful conflict
resolution tools
these instruments are all means to
achieve peace in Sudan
and
end that
we are convinced profoundly interests
the parties to the conflict and the
Sudanese people
we just emphasize that negotiation
between the rsf and the saf is not
surrendering from any side negotiation
is instead the first step to halting the
current military clashes providing
adequate protections for millions of
civilians in Sudan and avoiding
additional damage to essential civilian
infrastructure in cartoon on durman
Darfur and elsewhere
coexistence is a prerequisite it's among
the conditions that will enable the
parties to the conflicts to pave the way
for a political transition to a
civilian-led government
there will be no Sudanese ownership of
this political process without peaceful
coexistence between its leading military
and paramilitary forces
Madam President we sincerely hope the
Sudanese stakeholders realize the damage
that continues fighting has caused a
real cause to sue them and the Sudanese
people we call on them to engage
with the ongoing initiatives in good
faith
there is widespread international
support for reaching a peace deal
between the parties
the African union he got the league of
Arab states and partners of Sudan have
led the primary initiatives to reach a
ceasefire the next step is silencing the
guns and once and for all I thank you
China
City
[Music]
infrastructure
on track
s
and
other Regional organizations and
relevant countries when promoting peace
talks
even more
intentionally
thank you madam president
foreign
the security
silence
foreign
development and security situations
brick of violence must continue
secondary the humanitarian situations
women and girls are always most affected
devices
[Music]
agreement
the role regarding the social economics
over recent days
it is now facing
the agreement foreign
work on Sudan
Japan supports all efforts by the
trilateral mechanism so as to help
Sudanese people in need
at the time of the srs's previous
briefing on March the 20th we were
encouraged by the reporting about
Sudan's tradition process following the
signing of the framework agreement last
December
and the broad and inclusive workshops on
outstanding issues facilitated by the
trilateral mechanism of the African
Union you get and the United Nations
earlier this year
however April 15th everything changed
and Japan is alarmed by how rapidly the
situation has deteriorated
bearing this in mind I will mention
three points
first Japan reiterates its call on both
parties namely the Sudanese armed forces
and the rapid support forces to
immediately stop fighting and return to
a peaceful political process
we cannot accept any use of force that
undermines the sudanese-led and Sudanese
owned process toward the transition to
civilian rule as outlined in the
Constitutional Declaration of 2019.
and in this regard the Japan commands
Regional and international initiatives
to seek a lasting ceasefire and return
to political dialogue
second Japan is seriously concerned
about the humanitarian situation not
only in Sudan but in the neighboring
countries
more than one million people including
women and children are expected to flee
the country by October to seek security
and fulfill their basic needs according
to unhcr
we welcome the Jeddah the creation of a
commitment to protect the civilians of
Sudan and the agreement on the
short-term ceasefire and humanitarian
arrangements and asked the parties to
keep these agreements
Japan has decided to implement
assistance to Chad Egypt and South Sudan
through International organizations in
response to the influx of refugees
third the past stress is the importance
of maintaining in terms under these
difficult circumstances the council must
speak in a United United voice and
support the mission as it seeks to
revive the political process while also
maintaining the other three pillars of
its mandate
going forward we are ready to actively
contribute to discussions on how best to
adapt the mission strategic objectives
and operations to the rapidly changing
circumstances while ensuring that
council members have optimal insights
into the political dynamics that affects
its work
we also call on all the parties in Sudan
to ensure that new terms can carry out
its activities unhindered
allow me to conclude my statement by
reiterating or Firm support to the
mission under solidarity with the people
of Sudan as they face this unprecedented
challenge to the democratic transition
in which they have invested so much hope
and sacrifice I thank you
thanks special representative Perth for
your Sovereign briefing and I would also
like to take the opportunity to welcome
your new Deputy srsg inquetta salami to
her new role I welcome the participation
of the EU commissioner as well as the
egad executive secretary
and also the pr from Sudan
srsg pers the work you and your team
have done to advance unitem's mandate in
the current environment is truly
impressive and we appreciate that you
are doing this under extremely
challenging conditions
now more than ever it is critical that
the council's signal is full support for
the mission
colleagues this past weekend the Kingdom
of Saudi Arabia and the United States
announced that the Sydney's Security
Forces agreed to a short-term ceasefire
and humanitarian arrangement
we call on both parties to fulfill their
obligations under the seven-day
ceasefire and allow for humanitarian Aid
and relief assistance to reach those in
desperate need
the United States remains committed to
Bringing bringing a sustained into the
conflict in Sudan a conflict that has
inflicted immense pain and suffering on
the Sudanese people
we have heard disturbing reports of
attacks on civilians airstrikes on
hospitals sexual and gender-based
violence and looting
we must all do our part to bring about
peace and stability and we must do so
with urgency there is no time to waste
to this end we are in close cooperation
with our partners including the Kingdom
of Saudi Arabia the African Union egad
the league of Arab states and partners
in the quad tracker and Friends of Sudan
the United States welcomes the May 11th
Declaration of commitment to protect the
civilians of Sudan which recognized the
obligations of both sides under
International humanitarian law to
respect human rights and facilitate
humanitarian assistance
these obligations align with the goals
and intent of the eu's April 20th
communique and support the au's
forthcoming roadmap for de-escalation
as we work toward peace the United
States is committed to addressing the
dire humanitarian needs on the ground
more than 24 million people are now in
need of a humanitarian assistance a 57
percent increase over previous estimates
humanitarian agencies National ngos
Civil Society organizations professional
unions and neighborhood-based resistance
committees are going to incredible
lengths to deliver food provide medical
care resupply hospitals and support
evacuations but they cannot do this
heroic work without unhindered
humanitarian access
all parties must allow for immediate
safe and unhindered humanitarian access
for those in need and those displaced by
the fighting we support the un's
leadership and marshaling resources for
the Sudanese people including through
the newly revised humanitarian response
plan and we look forward to closely
coordinating efforts
for our part the United States is
committed to helping support the needs
of the more than 250 000 people who have
crossed into neighboring countries in
search of safety and the more than 840
000 people who are displaced inside
Sudan and cannot leave due to fighting
fuel shortages or fear
at the same time we must not forget the
needs of the 1.1 million refugees who
were in Sudan prior to the fighting we
appreciate and commend the work of
neighboring countries that have welcomed
sutiny's arrivals and we encourage all
countries to ensure that refugees and
Asylum Seekers have access to protection
and can eventually return to their
countries of origin voluntarily and with
when conditions permit
finally I'll note that the United States
continues to engage with Sudanese
civilian leaders resistance committees
and Civil Society to establish a
civilian-led democratic government as
soon as possible the United States
stands with the people of Sudan as they
push for Freedom peace and justice under
civilian Democratic Rule and we continue
to send a clear message to Sydney's
security forces in this senseless
conflict once and for all thank you
madam president
I thank the representative of the United
States
thank you madam president I wish to
begin by thanking our briefers today for
their very comprehensive updates on the
developments in Sudan and I welcome the
participation of the ambassador of Sudan
in this meeting
the UAE welcomes the short-term
ceasefire and humanitarian Arrangement
agreed and signed in Jeddah over the
weekend the agreement reinforces the
Jeddah Declaration of 11th May and forms
part of a step-by-step approach agreed
by the parties we thank the Kingdom of
Saudi Arabia and the United States for
their extensive efforts in facilitating
these important developments we urge
subsequent talks to improve the security
and humanitarian condition for civilians
on the ground leading to the necessary
political solution to this crisis and in
the meantime we stress that the details
of the recent agreement must be fully
implemented
the work of the United Nations on the
ground and of diplomatic missions has
been exceptional in extremely
challenging circumstances we strongly
condemn the vandalization of diplomatic
premises including the latest incidents
at the embassies of Kuwait Jordan and
Qatar diplomatic premises must be
protected in accordance with
international law including the Vienna
convention on diplomatic relations
since the beginning of the fighting the
UAE has sent nine planes to Sudan
evacuating almost 1 000 people
we continue to host and care for
Nationals from 26 different countries we
are also supporting neighboring
countries who have taken in refugees the
UAE dispatched 229 tons of Aid to Chad
to support displaced Sudanese and the
chadian government's humanitarian
response and we encourage all who can to
support those who have been displaced
there Still Remains much work to be done
the seven-day ceasefire and humanitarian
Arrangement signed over the weekend
Builds on the Jeddah declaration where
parties agreed to facilitate the safe
passage of Aid workers and the
distribution of humanitarian supplies
they also agreed to the unimpeded flow
of goods to restore essential services
and to withdraw forces from hospitals
and essential public facilities we hope
they will be able to make good on these
commitments the UAE would support the
security council's endorsement of the
Jeddah declaration and the short-term
ceasefire and humanitarian Arrangements
together the Declaration and the
short-term ceasefire must be built upon
within a wider format including partner
countries to promote confidence among
the parties
from what Felipe Grandy told the council
last week as well as recent data from
unhcr we know the number of refugees are
increasing more than 200 000 refugees
have now crossed over into neighboring
countries this is accelerating a
humanitarian crisis for the region at a
time when neighboring countries are
themselves under great strain in spite
of this we commend those neighboring
governments who have allowed people to
seek Refuge
the millions who remain in Khartoum and
other areas of Sudan face unacceptable
danger and are struggling to meet their
basic needs fuel shortages mean
hospitals do not have consistent power
the ongoing fighting makes it difficult
to replenish dwindling Food Supplies
leading to reported food shortages in
many areas
the alarm Bells continue to ring for all
of us
tragically the lives of many children
have also been upended or cut short by
the fighting according to UNICEF 190
children were killed during the first 11
days of the fighting alone with another
1700 injured most worryingly these
numbers are underreported children are
entitled to exceptional protections
under International humanitarian law and
this Council has called for special
measures to be taken to protect children
including in resolution resolution 2601
we commend the courageous efforts of the
Sudanese Frontline responders providing
emergency services and we reiterate our
call for All actors to abide by their
commitments measures such as flights
between Port Sudan and Addis are pivotal
for the welfare of civilians but they
are simply a stop gap for the permanent
ceasefire that we want to see in place
to ensure the continuity of relief
services
the only sustainable end to this
situation is through a political track
and this must include a broad array of
civil and political actors including
women
the UAE will continue to work with all
key Partners to support coordinated
mediation efforts at all levels the
United Nations the African Union egad
the OIC and the league of Arab states
have been committed to supporting Sudan
on its path to peace the solution does
lie in a broad regional approach with a
strong International backbone Madam
president the UAE believes that the
continued engagement of the United
Nations through unitams is critical and
we support the renewal of its mandate we
also support the work of the many un
agencies operating on the ground the
International Community must remain
Resolute in its commitment to
safeguarding the future of the Sudanese
people only by calling for a return to
the political track will this violence
be brought to a Swift and sustainable
end thank you madam president
and I also thank special representative
bertis for his briefing today as well as
commissioner adoia and executive
secretary Gabe who for their briefings
president following the outbreak of
clashes in hartum on 15 April will
reiterate our call on both parties to
seize hostilities without preconditions
and Lead Sudan back to a political
transition
we welcome the latest mediation efforts
including the Declaration of commitment
and the brokering of the upcoming
seven-day ceasefire
we believe that this is the only part
Jesus to peace and stability in Sudan
Malta strongly deploys the loss of life
and is deeply concerned that since the
beginning of the clashes over 800 people
have been killed including 200 children
and more than 5 000 injured
women and girls remain at a higher risk
of sexual and gender-based violence with
extensive reports of rapes and sexual
assaults
protection measures must be put in place
and strengthened for women and children
the elderly people with disabilities and
other vulnerable groups we cannot afford
to leave anyone behind
we remind all parties of their
obligations under International
humanitarian law and called for the safe
rapid and unhindered humanitarian access
towards civilians at all time at a time
when humanitarian needs in Sudan have
risen to record levels we also called
for their investigations and for
perpetrators to be brought to Justice
and held accountable for their crimes
Malta condemns all attacks on civilian
infrastructure including homes hospitals
schools and places of worship
we also condemn attacks on humanitarian
and medical workers and U.N premises
we are concerned that an estimated 14
million dollars worth of food products
destined to the most food insecure and
more than one million polio vaccines
intended for children have been
destroyed as a result of the Looting
it is clear that the conflict in Sudan
is having repercussions on The Wider
region
an estimated quarter of a million people
have fled Sudan with high number of
refugees and displaced markling a crisis
of regional proportions
as Sudanese and Third Country Nationals
fleeing from Sudan are facing various
Journeys we acknowledge the efforts
being made by neighboring countries and
hosting those seeking Refuge
at the same time we remain concerned
with the situation of in turn the
displaced in Sudan especially of women
residing in IDP camps that remain at
high risk of sexual and gender-based
violence the president
motor welcomes all efforts that seek to
support dialogue and mediation including
by the African Union the
intergovernmental authority of on
development the league of Arab states
and the United Nations and by
neighboring and other partner countries
recommend the efforts of the permanent
ceasefire committee chaired by unitams
and the civilian signature parties to
the framework agreement who have always
so Been instrumental in diffusing
tensions and promoting Community level
dialogue
all efforts must be inclusive including
women Youth and Civil Society
Malta will continue to support a
political settlement including three
unified messages by this Council
we urge both parties to hear and act on
these schools we express our full
support to osurus geppertis and unitums
for their unfiltering commitment to
Sudan's birth to towards stability
despite limited capacity
as we look forward to the missions
renewal we use today's meeting to also
call for this full Respect by the
authorities to UNI times mandates
president our message is clear it is
only with the silencing of the guns that
we can guarantee space for dialogue and
mediation and a solid foundation for
Sudan to return to the port towards the
civilian-led government peace and the
stable Democratic future
Madam president
of the intergovernmental Authority
developments
is deeply concerned
and
[Music]
to the previous result
a very difficult situation is developing
in the humanitarian area there are
growing flows of internally displaced
and refugees further escalation of the
situation could result in the worsening
of the security situation
but it can also just stabilize
neighboring countries which themselves
are in a very vulnerable situation
many of them are tackling their own
conflicts are receiving International
assistance
deployed on their territory
we need to understand
which led to the current out
confrontation
to a large extent the conflict is a
result
mismanagement when it comes to the
political settlement in Sudan and the
large degree of responsibility belongs
for a very long time that they have the
right to interfere in the internal
affairs of their country
the country
unfortunately the United Nations
Force the process of transferring